[Music]
thank you very much for attending this
session so today we'll be talking about
Ray architecting apps for cloud but why
how and so what let me introduce myself
my name is Norman Woodard I am with
Accenture and I am our global Apogee
practice lead I also am part of our
Accenture Google business group and so
my play as we call it within that as far
as an offering within that group is
actually dedicated to what we call
next-gen app development this is
entirely focused on micro services ap is
and containerization app modernization
andrey architecting for cloud is what we
do day in and day out so excited to be
here today let's get started so we're
seeing a paradox recently Accenture did
a survey of lots of different cxos and
different organizations and basically
what we found was that you know there's
there's a legacy debt that's in inside
of our platforms inside of the
infrastructure that comprised a lot of
the operating systems and basically your
business as you're doing it today with
NIT so what does this mean well the good
part is you've got data and they there's
lots of valuable information that's
useful to serve customers generate
revenue drive new business and
innovation however the bad part is and
there's therefore the paradox not able
to get access to that data so as much as
for example 70% of the c-suite
executives we talked to said that that
that trapped data that's inside those
monolithic applications typically is
what's severely limiting eyeties ability
to innovate in other words it's keeping
them back from being able to move
forward so they can't innovate they
can't adopt new platforms they're
challenged to be able to look at new
innovative products and technologies in
the marketplace so this is really
hamstrung and the ability for IT to keep
up with a pace of business so what does
this mean well part of it is that that
legacy dead is is holding the back
yes we've talked about that already but
what also means and more importantly as
the business it's not able to innovate
at speed so what that also starts to
create has a lot of a seat is
fragmentation so business may start
trying to do things on their own deve
try to deviate from IT and so you
started getting lots of discordant
discontinuity and services being able to
maintain those services and also operate
or scale those so technical debt as we
see it as what we've what I was just
defining the D locked in investments in
platforms technology development inside
those monolithic applications that's
creating not one a higher risk of
discontinuity so in other words more of
your systems are going to be apt to
break that cause outages cause service
disruptions and therefore impeding your
ability to service not only your
enterprise but also your your client
base as well you also have increased
complexity so lots of time and
investment into those applications lots
of data of course in there because
that's where your housing all of your
information both on your customers your
products your services and your
capabilities so what that's also doing
is that's creating a lock on on your
data and on what you're trying to be
able to carry the business forward on
so therefore what does lead to is
reducing eyeties ability to be nimble be
agile too it also affects their the
ability of IT to be healthy and a
respect of being to provide new services
business continuity constant uptime but
also create nimbleness and effectiveness
in being able to move the move the
services and the capabilities forward in
order to innovate at the speed at which
business is looking to operate so when
we talk about drivers of app
modernization getting ready to move to
cloud what do you--what needs you know
what does that whole aspect look like
what are we talking about so getting
ready to RER Kotak move to either
container eyes and and be more nimble
inside of the back-office
or move to cloud or even hybrid cloud as
we see most of our clients doing today
so drivers of that optimization cloud
migration is going to be primarily
either kind of the obvious right so it's
either business driven so there's
business priorities either new
innovation or revenue they may be
cost-cutting aspects as well from the
business side or it can be IT driven so
whether its infrastructure LED
technology legacy end-of-life systems or
drivers to consolidate platforms
licensing costs other other lock'd
factors in terms of driving up the IT
budget so cost reduction being a primal
importance and then also the cost of
maintenance not just in terms of dollars
but also the resources required to
maintain those platforms and
infrastructure so new approach needs to
be taken how do you get started where do
you what does this journey look like so
we're trying to simplifying it down just
three simple aspects so first off let's
start with assess develop a consistent
measured approach to how you're going to
remediate how are you going to get ready
to re-architect your apps we architect
your infrastructure and your services
and be able to provide that path towards
elasticity scalability and manageability
essentially then used use technology so
the best practice as we see it in what
we advise our clients and also I don't
mean just advice I mean we implement
this for a lot of clients day in and day
out digital decoupling new new way of
using an old term and it's my phrase so
I'll play with a little bit here but
we've heard digital decoupling I'm sure
many of you have before what does this
really mean so it's separating out your
technology it's providing a an
abstraction layer that you don't start
from a scratch approach you're laying in
on top and with that you're providing an
infrastructure to be able to decouple
your services from your back-end
platforms and then enable the separation
from your apps and your in your systems
of record and your systems of engagement
and then next is going to be evolved so
now it's a matter of as you start laying
that foundation you move towards what
with the decoupling you're gonna move
towards a API centric microservices a
containers approach to all of your
applications and your services now take
it to the next step and that is evolved
to where you're making it more elastic
you make a de tour you can expand your
services your capabilities you've got a
framework for managing not only security
but also managing the services have
visibility not only to performance but
also to what data is being passed how
it's being passed and being able to
scale those services so that your
infrastructure is servicing your
applications and not your applications
being the your end customer but actually
driving the use of the data to enable
the business so how do you start
eliminating and preventing this
technical debt well the technical debt
starts typically all these investments
is we're just talking about a minute ago
the monolithic application or
applications there can be more than one
right so tell my CRM product product
databases HR numbers of different
systems supply chain you've got multiple
that are typically existent in every
enterprises we've all started evolving
we started with the the best and breed
at the time well those have you know
technologies involved absolutely volved
now there's new stuff out rate of change
that we all experience today but what
this also means is now you need to as
you're looking to reaaahhr tech their
applications and enable more of a cloud
native ready infrastructure and your
approach the applications and I'll start
taking it - are you decoupling your
services from those monolithic
applications break out those services
break out that data and expose it to
where you can actually access it your
application developers are able to
incorporate those services consume those
into applications far easier and
therefore you're able to create reusable
assets rather than constantly creating
the same connection the same interface
the same API or micro service to a
number of different applications so now
you're going towards developing reusable
assets and then you've got a basis where
you can start creating scalability and
be able to manage that approach so entry
points where do you start where does
this journey begin
what do you jump in every Enterprise is
going to be different and with that
every application it's going to be at a
different stage in its lifecycle your
business is gonna have a different entry
point so where is the business and I
don't mean IT so I'm separating animals
out for a second but I t's gonna have
separate driver so you need to
understand what are the what are the
factors that are driving them to want to
move the application or capability to
cloud in this case same thing apply if
you're keeping it on Prem principles
that are very very similar right
so is it innovation are they trying to
offer new capabilities new services are
they trying to provide business
continuity are they is it revenue
impacting or is it cost reduction and
what are the business drivers that's
important factor to understand and then
also related to it from the IT side of
the house is assess the current state of
the application where's it add in its
maturity where's it at in its evolution
ru is IT and business for that matter
cloud ready do you have those is that
support and infrastructure in place and
what are the prior priority drivers for
from an IT perspective is a cost
reduction is infrastructure
consolidation is it application renewal
refresh just understanding those and
then from there you can start to begin
to figure out all right using this
framework as you're seeing in front of
you leveraging the aspect the concept of
decoupling where does it begin to fit
together so now you can pick where is
the appropriate entry point and you
start from there so it's usually
understanding these these aspects first
knowing that you're going to go towards
a digital decoupling an API and
microservice containerization approach
and then there it starts okay so now
getting into a proof of concept look at
your architecture
proof of concepts on your services make
sure you don't forget about security and
also from the development how are the
these services going to be access and
maintain so it's important to have all
four aspects incorporated into some of
those proof of concepts to
validate the approach validate the
business goals are going to be met with
the with the approach of the
architecture and the infrastructure and
then you start on your way towards going
towards implementation
all right so building blocks so look at
change data capture right so look at how
data is captured see how that's going to
play into and understand how that's
going to affect your infrastructure and
your applications look at your
event-driven architecture how is you you
know what are the what are the events
that are gonna be driven what are the
applications and platforms they're gonna
be driving those events what data needs
to be captured how was it going to be
processed and what does it also going to
be triggering then you start looking at
micro services and your API so what's
your API and micro service strategy with
Google and what I enjoy working with
very passionately for the last five
years definitely Apogee and then
leveraging Misty oh and and kubernetes
it's real strong platforms be able to to
springboard off and provide this
infrastructure on a robust scale so this
is what we do a lot with our clients and
that's all that we going to lead to an
approved user experience so being able
to deliver faster but also improve that
user experience to where they're getting
better more and more value out of those
applications and driving how they're
going to be able to not only use the app
but also driving the adoption of the app
and the services as well all right so
with this I'm going to turn it over to
my colleague and he'll walk you through
the next steps on how do you start this
journey and what's our approach hey good
morning everybody so my name is Mamoon
Halle my role with Accenture is
primarily leading the solution delivery
and architecture for North America and I
have been in the industry for more than
20 years primarily building custom
applications on different architectural
styles for a variety of customers and
industries and today what I'm going to
be going over is talk about how we can
take the concepts that Norman mentioned
and distill them into an approach that
risk mitigated has been worked out with
customers in the past and then
what are the things that you need to
watch out for so that when you go
implement this type of journey you are
successful and minimize the amount of
risk and hopefully your c-level suite
would be impressed by what you have done
as part of the process so let's start
talking about the exponential
architecture and what does that mean
from taking an existing monolith or
legacy type of system and trying to
modernize those type of systems and get
them into a shape where I can fulfill my
primary two drivers for building any
type of system whether I want to reduce
cost or I want to increase agility and
innovation right so for the past 20 plus
years this has been the two drivers that
driving the majority of the projects
that I have worked on and this is no
different so it's always that question
that we have to answer and what type of
metrics that we need to put up front to
make sure that we are successful as part
of the process and as you can imagine
this is not an easy task
so in order to get there safely you have
to kind of put some kind of baby steps
in place so that you can get to that
journey in a kind of governed approach
so that you can scale later down the
road and if you need to fail you fail
fast as part of agile type of principles
and you adjust based on the results that
you have went through as part of the
initial steps of that process and that's
exactly what this number one showing
here you need to start small right and
as part of that process you need to
define what we call a proof of
architecture where you can go through
these type of processes and you craft
out some use cases as part of your
domain you define one or two use cases
that would touch upon many of the
systems that you are going to touch so
it there are no cutting corners here the
reason we cut corners Gallus into
technical debt and we got into where we
are right now because of that so as part
of your POA you want to address those
hard questions in order to make sure
that you don't get surprises down the
road right so you try to put to use
cases you try to touch upon many of the
layers of the architecture that you're
building and then you execute and then
you figure out what is the outcome of
that execution and what the things that
went right for
things that may have not and what type
of tweaks enhancements that I need to do
as part of the process so that I can get
to the latter stages of the process
where I can optimize and scale and
deliver all of these type of things with
certainty and good results as part of
the process so that's really what this
thing is all about here to make sure
that we we get into these type of steps
I've seen many clients in the past where
they go and start hesitating or things
don't go well because there are so many
things that they needed to iron out
before going and doing starting anything
and we've seen that pattern and and the
the way around that is to define exactly
what type of objectives that you want to
do and use those guiding principles to
if discussions happen or conflict arises
use these metrics principles to kind of
guide you through the process and try to
make decisions and move forward and this
is what I mentioned as a part of the
proof of architecture so we select the
business priorities what is that we want
to accomplish there are definitely
certain business priorities that we want
to accomplish pick one or two use case
start with the high level architecture
blueprint if I'm going to use micro
services event-driven type of
architecture what are the primary
components what are the primary
scenarios and then start small in terms
of your DevOps I understand that when
you go and look at develop step of
articles you have these 10-12 tools that
are all integrated and nicely mature
fashion but is that really what you want
initially from the get-go most likely
not I haven't seen one customer started
with that right so you need to start
with what makes sense for you
one two tools to start with doesn't have
to be perfect you can start with that
learn the lessons add additional tools
find the gaps and incrementally move
over until you kind of get to that stage
where now I know exactly what I'm trying
to accomplish
I learned the lessons and now I can
continue a cycle of evaluation and
building till you finalize that state
where you get into the optimization mode
and building at scale and having any
factory or setup that you want to do
down the road now to talk about digital
decoupling in terms of kind of more
peeling the layers of the onion there
are twelve steps that we have seen with
working with customers you know
you may emerge one step into the other
or whatever doesn't matter but the
process stays the same right whether
it's ten twelve you have to cover your
bases as part of what's needed as part
of the digital decoupling so starting
with defining the domains trying to
understand what is it that I want to
build what type of business problem that
I'm trying to tackle what type of issues
all the way down to decoupling the
organization and reaching out into a
state where things are running in a
smooth fashion so let's take step by
step into figuring out what these things
mean and how they figure out into
digital decoupling so the first thing I
need to understand is what are my
logical boundaries right if you're an
airline company you have two types of
models potentially you have a word
booking on our booking if you're an L if
you're on a bank you may have commercial
banking retail banking right and so on
every customer knows their primary
domains and what am I trying to focus on
I'm trying to focus on a or B and then
within a or B what are the priorities
that I want to get if I'm having issues
with issuing policies for my customers
it's taking extraordinary amount of time
to do that because of my monolith and
then there are certain rules that nobody
knows about is there something that I
can do to fix that is that part of my
prioritization my scenarios that I want
to tackle as part of the process and
then trying to understand the
interdependencies right so you probably
at the beginning of the stage you don't
want to pick something where there are
so many interdependencies on that type
of particular capability because that's
going to complicate your life pick
something that is not necessarily
trivial but don't go and pick the most
complex type of scenario and you're
saying I'm going to start with that
right so pick something somewhere in the
middle it touches upon many aspects of
the organization and there is value
associated with that and try to start
applying domain-driven design and to
kind of layering down what are the
things that I need to do as part of the
process and try to understand those type
of things that are inter playing
together to deliver that type of
capability so that when I go and start
carving out or hollowing out that
particular monolith I understand the
ramifications of what that is right then
we start looking into the interfaces so
as
of the process we start looking if we
pick one domain let's say it's property
and I have different capabilities I want
to tackle underwriting billing and
policy issuance as part of the process
great these are part of the vocabulary
that we want to do and there are certain
things that we use and then we made the
decision we want to be even driven
architecture we start looking at what
type of events that needs to be issued
as part of the process right so we're
trying to decouple we try to put
flexible infrastructures in place so
that these systems can inter communicate
as part of the process so as part of
this you start high-level defining the
interfaces identifying the micro
services and identification of micro
services can be another thing that you
may want to consider we'll talk about it
towards the end but it's at a high level
you start doing that and as part of
doing that you also start identifying
what type of synchronous asynchronous
type of activities that would need to go
with those you may want to look at the
velocity of data changes you may want to
look at you know how big the data is all
of these good things that you need to
understand about the interface would be
required and you need to find a way to
start documenting that as part of the
process and then that's the next step
which we talked about we now look into
the data in more particular detail now
it's not enough I talked about these
particular attributes and these micro
services I now look at what is the right
structure for this type of data is that
adjacent document that needs to flow
between a and B systems
what is that contract starts looking at
and then we start kind of start locking
into what that contract looks like and
finalizing those steps and once you
finalize those contracts that's what
other people within the team whether
it's offshore development or whatever it
is we will need to start looking into
and testers will start looking into what
type of testing plans they need to
create so that becomes part of what you
need to start looking into in terms of
governance and making sure that further
changes to certain type of interfaces
would require some additional steps so
it's not just let's go and scratch that
field and put something else here as
quickly as we wanted to right so that
type of activity would need to be
checked as part of the process and then
when you start looking at your services
and selecting the right building blocks
right there are many ways that you can
build this you can whether use the
technology from Google or different
providers each cloud provider would give
you certain different type of
capabilities we all know probably
kubernetes is emerging to be the global
universal runtime now for all of this
micro services type of activities
functions as service is emerging to be
one of those things that lots of
companies are discussing and and trying
to figure out what they want to do and
then there are things related to your
infrastructure how you build your
infrastructure as part of the process so
that when I go and deploy my code do I
expect that environment to be there or
do I expect to have scripts that go and
build that environment for me and then
once I build that environment that could
get deployed as part of the process
there are different ways to look at that
but these are part of the decisions that
you have to make right as part of your
organization some of those decisions may
be appropriate up front some of them may
become later down the road as you gain
maturity and appreciate the level of
complexity that would be required as
part of those type of activities and
then you know it's the the selection of
the right framework is important as well
some companies may be familiar with one
framework versus the other don't force
yourself into something just because
company X is doing it if you have
certain best practices within your
organization that you're comfortable
happy with go ahead and use that and
everything that has to be selected would
need to be rationalized for the process
and then we start looking at okay great
I started defining those things now we
look more into hollowing out the core
and primarily using the Strangler
pattern right so trying to be getting
things out until some point that
monolith does not have any reason to
live and we kind of take things out
sometimes you may not be able to be as
lucky and completely eliminate that
monolith for various reasons you may
have to provide some access around those
type of activities but at least you can
take that monolith and hollow out let's
say 70 80 90 percent as part of the
process if you're like
get 200% and then continue with that so
that's important thing and then you
start looking at what type of business
logic where would that need to be
existing and what type of capabilities
that we start taking out from that
monolith and definitely those are
services that you have identified later
and business logic that would need to go
and live in those type of services that
you would need to create and then we
look closely at the events right so we
start looking at these micro services
they're communicating or decoupling
we're isolating so what is the pattern
of communication between micro services
and that's a decision that you want to
make are you going to allow your micro
services to talk to each other right and
you know that's a question that you know
we've seen it fullcycle 15-20 years ago
everybody's thought that the
criss-crossing mesh of everything
talking to each other is not a good idea
we created the bus and then when baby I
get when I would service meshed what
micro services we're saying well
services can talk to each other right
it's up to you everybody has their
comfort zone but you know if you take
that pattern to an extreme understanding
that business code the logic if many of
these services start talking to each
other you're creating a lot of spaghetti
code down the road so that's just
something that despite what everybody
says about this pattern you can use it
judiciously but don't go overboard with
allowing these things happening and
events would be one way to look at it or
isolating the communication as well
another way and then you want to look at
data application change data capture
right so when things happen when certain
state gets updated
are there any type of ramifications on
other consumers who may be interested in
that state how are you handling those
type of things are you handling those
through events or events on a
combination of CDC or CDC or whatever it
is that you're doing right so these are
decisions that you want to talk about
and then you start looking at the
variety of the flows that you need to
have whether it's sync async
fire-and-forget or events truly events
right those needs to be they're not
everything will be event-driven
and if you mandate that everything will
be event-driven you will be disappointed
because there will be a time where batch
or
micro batch would be required as part of
your architecture so you would have to
have certain provisions within your
architecture to go figure out how are
you going to handle those what does that
mean from security and boundaries
perspective whether I want to enable
enable certain scenario a or B or C or D
right so these are important things and
questions too to understand and as
Norman mentioned earlier the user
experience really is one of these things
that would drive many of those decisions
right before we go into any of these
type of digital decoupling the objective
is to create something cool and fancy
and enables me to be more innovative
agile etc so we typically start with a
very nice idea that we employ Design
Thinking as part of the process and we
start idea ting and we come up with a
very nice business value that would
allow me based on that type of scenario
if I carve out a piece of it that would
allow me to be a differentiated type of
offering with speed to market against my
competitors right so let those type of
decisions kind of dictate what are the
things that you need to do rather than a
blanket statement saying everything is
event-driven right because there are
tendencies for companies or
organizations or humans that the herd
mentality everybody is doing this we
follow without necessarily thinking is
that the right approach for me or my
organization or my type of scenarios
that I want to enable as part of the
process and one of the important things
that you need to be aware of is the the
rest of the architecture right as you
probably thinking in your mind right now
it's like this is not a trivial endeavor
right there are many moving parts when
you take an existing monolith into a
micro service route things were much
easier and if I'm anybody says
differently I would disagree with that
you know much easier to have one big
java application or whatever it is that
everything happens there I just do one
build one release etc not certainly a
good way to release business value I
would give you that but if you were to
start looking at the micro service route
and all of these type of moving parts
that you're introducing as part of the
mix you're adding a lot of complexity to
the question
so that's something that you have to be
prepared for right whether that
complexity lies in in CI CD security
team structure whatever it is the
management of these services I used to
manage one system now I have 20 micro
services what do you do with that I had
five error codes now I potentially have
20 error codes right all of these things
you have to be thinking about and what
does that mean to your organization and
your structure and then we get to the
proof of architecture step that we
talked about earlier right
get these two primary two use cases
slice it across many layers of the
system see how this thing would behave
and make sure that you you figure out
how your team later on would be able to
support this type of model right and you
know there is the next step where we go
and just industrialize and making sure
that we get into automation and all
these type of things once we master the
basis and we expand only as necessary so
that's important because many people
think you just grow the team add more
bodies to it I'll be able to scale that
doesn't work with micro services micro
services require those fully functional
teams where I want to have people kind
of with different variety of skills
working as one unit and that has been
the best practice for developing micro
services rather than having a team that
does a or B or C independently data
middleware you name it right so you want
to make sure that these things are part
of covered as part of the process and
then there are certain kind of metrics
in terms of the plumbing how much time
you need to be spending on plumbing
versus other things right plumbing
shouldn't be taking more than 20% if you
started a project and you're seeing that
you're spending more than 20% of your
time on lots of plumbing activities
you're going overboard right so make
sure that you don't as you're part of
initial plan or whatever plans that you
put making sure that those type of
things are covered as part of the
process
now Conway's law it's something that was
coined back in the 1968 time frame
basically says organizations tend to
create functions or capabilities or
systems based on their own
infrastructure or their own
communication style org structure right
so you have websites matching the
structure of the organization and
that is not necessarily good for how you
want to move forward you just need to be
aware of that and and and that
particular bias that we have as part of
building systems in the past and my
objective is to move from I was working
with a company and their middleware
division they had 200 people just 200
people just to do the middleware another
like 50 or 60 people just to do data
another team doing ETL it's a massive
type of organization with more than like
probably like 3,000 people in their IT
division but that gives you an idea and
things moved at a very snail pace as
part of that that will not work with
micro services you want to make sure
that you know you have nimble teams
there are people and brain trusts within
the team to make decisions there has to
be a common ground somewhere not
everybody goes doing their own thing but
you would need to make sure that you
have that common ground and then give
the team's the authority and have the
skills within the team so that they can
function as a unit that's basically
effective and productive at the end of
the day so let's briefly look at DCP
view and what that means so so at
Accenture you know we've seen this
problem we've seen it many times so
we've built some assets around them and
we built some logical architecture along
with additional physical components that
goes along with it and that's what you
would see if you were to go and build it
yourselves you would have to go and
figure out ok I'm doing some type of
event hub which is primarily the the
bread-and-butter of these type of
systems and then I have to have certain
level of micro services you have to make
the decision is micro service would have
its own database are you going to share
the databases different pros and cons of
each one of them the the the school of
thought most likely the tables now are
separate independent so that you can run
your micro services completely
independent scale independently and
independence also means if I deploy that
service I will not impact anybody else
right so these are part of the things
that you need to talk about as you
identify micro services that is you make
these architectural decisions about
micro services and what is a micro
service what level of granularity of a
micro service that you are going to
create as
part of the process for which particular
domain and what are the objectives right
so these are things that we have built
some intelligence around them and as
part of that exponential architecture we
typically see the pattern of data like
how many of you have done a data leak or
trying to implement a data leak today
lots of hands and those who did not
raise their hands you will be because
that's a pattern right now that lots of
companies are gaining a lot of business
traction value out of that
so the analytics the AI the capabilities
that you can get out of that they are
significant and those leaders in the
industry know that right and they are
starting their journeys as part of the
data leak so as part of this you'll see
data leak I services on top of that can
be invoked through serverless type of
capabilities or whatever way you want
them to be invoked right and then you
have the Gateway on top to isolate and
kind of govern many of those aspects and
then you have your consumers up top
driven by that user experience that you
created through design thinking and
making sure that I'm going to do that
right now if you translate that to
products and constructs this is how it
looks like and by no means this is a
representative of a slice of a company
or any type of assets all what this is
representing is these are options right
so you see that you have East your
darker kubernetes containers cloud run
etc listed there do I read functions as
well do I really need to go and
implement all of that the answer is no
these are options for you to consider
right and each one of those who take a
probably half an hour discussion to go
over the details but I would encourage
each one of you to look at what this
thing is all about and then the the
major question that also needs to come
into is the event hub are you part of
GCP going to use pub/sub and I put Kafka
there even though it's not DCP but it's
coming to DCP through confluent and
potentially other things but Kafka is
also is one of those things that you
really can't have that discussion
without talking about Kafka and then
what are you
acquirements you know things related to
indefinite storage or order of messages
things can be done in DCP nothing sadly
out of the box but you can create around
them right so we can do that it doesn't
mean that we can but there are companies
who would prefer certain things to be
done in certain way and it would be a
mess if I don't put Kafka there as part
of the event hub right and then there
are the things related to called
functions streaming IOT core all of
these type of activities that you need
to do cdc tap / application you know
what do you do about them as part of the
process so take that one look at it and
an Apogee obviously as part of the API
gateway is one of these core components
that would give you a lot of flexibility
as part of your architecture here's
another view of the how that may looks
like what additional capabilities
flushed out around Apogee as part of the
process so it's it's really something
that not necessarily highly different
from what I'd displayed earlier it's
just something that you need to do you
know firestore is one of these newer
products that that Google released last
year and you know the model basically
does not dictate whether you use
database a or B or C you can use
multiple databases as you can use
multiple languages as part of your micro
service implementation so again what
your requirements are do you use the
same database for the read/write of view
or something different right so it's all
depending on what you want to do and if
somebody was wondering where is the
marketing slide this is the one I
promise it's on the one slide it just
basically shows we've been there done
that we have lots of assets and we can
help you I'm not going to expand on it
anymore but you know we've been in the
business for a long time we know what we
talk about when we talk about that so
let me briefly discuss the sowhat right
and I touched upon items of the Sawat
and that's really the the you know if
there is the message that we need to
take out it's really considering the so
what what does that mean for my
organization right there are many things
to take out from this presentation but
governance for example and I had that as
a little G actually but somebody updated
it with a capital G perfectly fine
little G versus capital G basically
means I don't want to be the
so this is a little G just for the
record so capital G basically means you
raise the stick of rules regulations for
everything that you want to do little G
basically means I have rails guidelines
and I empower you to do anything you
want to as long as you stay within the
rails just simple analogy as much as
that right so that's a question that you
need to think about as you start
creating micro-services as to start
creating api's how you want to cover
them design time run time right all of
these sample things as you think about
them design patterns there are many
design patterns that have been
established the command query response
separation reads writes for
micro-services saga patterns for
transactions no fees commit in in
micro-services so if you have two phase
commit requirements how can you handle
that as part of micro services write
events compensating events things that
you need to consider event sourcing is
that something that you would be
interested in replaying type of things
when changed with state changes and you
have some discrepancy and I can go and
and and repeat all of these things and
recover the state at certain point right
all driven by requirements don't get
into the mode of where people are doing
this for everything and therefore I need
to do this no absolutely not
there are lots of complexities
associated with that and let the
requirements drive it yes keep an eye on
future requirements just so we don't
introduce too much rework
but let the Kreuk requirements drive
what is that right I talked about
service identification and reuse so
that's another thing that you may want
to factor in yes independency great but
I want to make sure that I am at the
right level of granularity and this is
going to be a reusable service if I'm
creating a service just for the sake of
creating a service that's going to be
used only once you would have to think
about that right as part of the process
I want to touch briefly on the team
structure so I talked about it as well
but team structure is one of these
things that many organizations think
that we can just have a micro services
team that handles all micro services
right that is not necessarily the right
way to do it right so you would want to
have the separation between different
teams you can have multiple tee
handling micro-services and you have the
brain trust and these teams to be kind
of nimble enough it doesn't necessarily
mean one way or right or the other way
is wrong if you have a micro services
team within your organization and that's
working for you all power to you right
but if you are starting to look at it
from scratch that would be one of the
things to think about as part of the
process the networking security and I am
you know that's a fundamental question
that you have to go through with every
GCP implementation right you would have
to spend a decent amount of time
typically six to eight weeks ten weeks
depending on your complexity the
environment to build the environment in
a production i's grade type of fashion
but for that POA it doesn't have to be
that long I can start very quickly very
fast in about a week two weeks put it in
a sandbox and and go quickly on that
while the other environment is being
built out in a production grade type of
fashion right so do two things in
parallel that would save you down the
road as part of the process so with that
I will hand it back over to my colleague
here Thank You C if you're with me if
you would move alright so give you a
small little case study examples of some
of the things we did and and kind of
with results where I'm not going to go
into it real detail but basically rising
costs compute time need to move migrate
to cloud more channels being driven
wouldn't have more access channels for
consumers as well as partners so this
particular financial institution really
was trying to be very innovative
leapfrog ahead of where the competition
was but also really enable more services
to get to their end users and also buy
any users met not only consumers but
also their customer care their their
data banking the retail store banking
service agents so it was really kind of
a comprehensive program they were
stymied by having again monolithic
applications monolith infrastructure if
you will so in other words legacy very
much slow wasn't API driven didn't have
reusable assets everything was very
difficult to not only break out and step
great from services perspective but also
incorporate that data and services into
modern digital applications so overall
surprise surprise right so their compute
time went down when you move to cloud
yay there's lots of good benefits here
so I'm not trying to minimize or
belittle that well what I really want to
help you focus on is while they became
more nimble and their innovation and
being able to get services out to the
market faster oh by the way that was
more than typically more than 50% that's
significant
so they reduced their cycle time for
getting new services out more than 50%
and able to roll out multiple services
not just one big project and oh by the
way that really increase in revenue as
well as their market stance market
positioning because now they were more
prominent they were to reach more of
their their end users and it actually
catapulted them up and understandings
within their market segments so what
else well security and fraud did also
with the new services new capabilities
they had additional benefits of having
better security but more manageable
services and better response to their
security penetration and also their
security architecture downside that they
didn't anticipate it actually took them
a while internally to go through their
own internal security and regulation
process to break out those monoliths so
there were some aspects that they didn't
anticipate they still got business value
they still created that nimbleness they
created that decoupling layer they used
Apogee and they use containers and so
they were able to achieve those results
but what they didn't anticipate is again
looking inside the business and aligning
business goals business priorities and
business objectives with IT capabilities
and eyeties priorities so that they were
reaching towards a common goal hugely
important so putting this pulling us all
together kind of what I talked about
what my colleague mamoon talked about
when it comes to re-architect for cloud
you you've gotten a lot of information
today hopefully is very useful to you
but really it's it comes down to if
were to simplify it three different
areas right so enabling growth and
agility enabling that innovation and
ability to introduce new capabilities
new services through differentiated and
modular core capabilities that you have
enabled through cloud ready
infrastructure also you want to address
current stability issues you want to be
able to it will enable you to address
not only your current business
continuity plan but also enable a robust
infrastructure to your where your going
to be able to continue to launch new
services without service disruption and
be able to compartmentalize what you do
have any service or security impacts
that you can minimize the the overall
proliferation of those incidents right
and then of course every IT group and
every CIO wants to hear oh we're gonna
reduce costs too but again it has to be
done in the right way you could end up
spending 3 X 4 X 10 x times which needs
to be done without the proper planning
so the proper planning is so critical
little G setting up the process but with
a big G emphasis on getting it right do
the right planning up front don't pass
that it is so critical to have the right
plan figure out what you need to do how
to get and achieve the goals you're
trying to get to but to find those goals
more concretely don't just say
don't just let a utopian guidance of a
high level I want to go API centric how
are you gonna get there what's your
microservices plan what's your support
plant
what's your design stay your your run
stay how are your data stores what's
your services continuity plan gonna be
what is that infrastructure supposed to
look like set that framework in place
first define at a high level and then
without going to the nth degree don't
get into paralysis by analysis but take
the baby steps and start implementing
today what you need to but plan for
tomorrow keywords alright so wrapping
this all up digital decoupling some
guiding principles layering apply
layering to isolate your systems isolate
your approach you know implement
appropriate fragmentation so remove the
the pieces that are gonna cause
congestion could cause conflicts in your
architecture and your infrastructure in
the applications but also in your
governance process to as mamoon said
love it keep with a small G therefore
you're driving adoption of your
infrastructure your systems and your
approach and tool sets that you're
putting in place for API use micro
services and containers right
simplify for those of you engineers I
want to keep it simple stupid right or
otherwise and very important it can't
oversimplify that we're not to play on
it but in order to drive adoption enable
self-service enable your business to get
in and develop their own API give them
the infrastructure and the capacity and
the tool sets and the guidance to have
design standards so you have
standardization and development but of
course so you maintain some visibility
secure ability and manageability of
those services differentiated services
break them out and then automate those
as well right automate the entire
process incorporate it into your CI CD
process all the way through and that
includes through even your API platform
one of the great things I love about
Apogee as a tool set from an API
perspective for implementations because
there's so much that you can do
leveraging kubernetes in this do and
then bring it all together in your CI CD
pipeline with Apogee script it out to
where you can validate even what your
security policies are hugely important
that automation process it'll save time
and money it's not a big investment from
instilling those process of developing
those capabilities in that automation so
don't overlook that cloud we all know
about building your intelligence
building utility just to not only
monitor performance but also look at how
your data is being used look at how your
services are being used who's requesting
what who are those end users so that you
can understand where your data and the
data requesting is actually how that's
driving your business a very important
point and understanding of where you
need to expand and continue on your
design patterns and then making
everything available in real time that
visibility just continues to play on
building in that intelligence
in your cloud and bringing it all
together
[Applause]
[Music]